[音楽]
danejones
私たちはこの話5特に同世代の同じ時代に生きる仲間たちに贈りたいと思います
かれこれ10年以上にわたって私たちは社会に育ててもらってきました
7つ離れた姉と一緒に自分たちが思いついた菜の花元気プロジェクトをすぐに小さく
始め
しかし結局は社会の多くの方々に協力をしてもらってきたのです
その結果私たちは本当に感謝しきれないほどたくさんのものをもらってきたような気が
します
私たちは今までこの3つの行動を繰り返してきました
第一に何かをとことん好きになる
第二にそれについて誰かに話し行動する
第三に行動した結果を文章に書く
このとてもシンプルな3つの行動です
第一に
人は何かをとことん好きになるとそれを自分ごととして考えるようになります
10年前9台キャンパスの移転によって寂れてしまった
地元六本松も
4年前熊本自身で枯れてしまった
南阿蘇の使用車水源も大好きな場所でした
自分が大好きだったものが傷つけば自分のことのように心が痛みます
その時誰のものでもないだからこそ私たちのものでもあるのではないかと思ったのです
第二にこういった想いを私たちは家族に話しました
兄弟とも私たちに何かできないだろうかと話し合いました
そして中学1年生だった私は球団や土地を管理していた ur や国道を管轄する国土
省に交渉し続けついにはその思いが通じて交渉したすべての土地を貸していただきまし
た
私たちは菜の花の種をまき次の年の春
六本松を幸せ色の黄色い菜の花で彩りました
テレックス効果に登壇させてもらったのはこの頃です
また熊本地震の際には南阿蘇村の試合車水源近くに住む人たちを何度も取材し
地震当日の大自然の恐ろしさやその日まで生活に欠かせなかった
水源の清らかな水のありがたさについてのお話を伺いました
第三にこれらの活動を1年ごとに振り返り
毎年作文に書きました
六本松の街を励まし地域の人とつながり
町おこしの祭りを盛り上げ
東北の被災地に有志で増やした種を送り
多くの被災者住宅をなの花で彩って励ましたこと
あるいは枯れ果てた足を医者制限が奇跡的に復活を果たすまでの地元の人たちのドラマ
と感動も共有したこと
月日がたっても被災地は今も復興の真っただ中であることをみんなに忘れて欲しく
なかったのです
私たちはこの3つの行動を繰り返すことで気がつけば多くの方々と心をつなぐことが
できることを学びました
誰かのために自分からと行動し始めたつもりが気がつけば私たちこそが社会の方々に
助けられ育てていただいていたのです
途中投げ出したくなるような時もありました
しかしそんな辛い上り坂の時こそ自分が成長させてもらっていたのだと感謝の気持ちで
胸がいっぱいになります
この秋南阿蘇村に菜の花の種を蒔いてきました
夢スゴ世界ジオパークにも認定される大自然の持つパワーを発信源として
被災地をつなぐ復興のプラットフォームを作ることが今の目標です
近年の異常気象から毎年のように起こる自然災害は報道も追いつかないほどです
被災地を忘れない
一方の道のりを一緒に分かち合う
そんなプラットフォームを作りたいと思っています
誰のものでもないだからこそ私たちのものでもあるという考えを一人一人が持つことで
世界的な環境問題も自分ごとに思えてきます
そこで勇気を出して小さな一歩を踏み出し人と心をつなぐ
その感動を私たちは知っています
誰もがこの感動を知るべきです
きっとそこには誰かのために自分から動く
あなたがいます
そしてきっとそのそばには誰かの笑顔があるはずです
誰のものでもないだからこそ私のものでもある
誰かのために自分から
あなたが踏み出す一歩は何ですか
[音楽]